hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today I'm answering
a question from one of my newsletter
readers Jason who just lost his job and
he's trying to get started in a new
business and is wondering how to make
money to be able to get going so
hopefully I can answer is watching for
it so Jason wrote in saying good morning
my name is Jason from Sacramento
California just last week I lost my job
yes things are a bit stressful in the
house but surprisingly my wife has been
very supportive she knows that my
passion and dreams are in personal
development motivations speak in a
relationship advisor expert field
although I strongly feel the urge to
rush and get another nine-to-five job I
feel that now is the time to go for my
passion well I want to get started in
this field and really make my passions
realize I love how you set the trail for
others who have this passion to also
during this time I need to put my income
preferably at home you have any
knowledge of what would be available to
do that I see all these network
marketing ventures but they just give me
the flags up feeling what do you suggest
I don't want to the rest of my life just
making $30,000 a year anymore my family
and myself deserve a lot more out of
life losing this job might be a blessing
as one might put it now I have the time
to really be all that I can be and I
would love for you to be a direct part
in it any words of advice at this time
we very much appreciate it and yes just
in case you're wondering yes I'm willing
to really listen to what you have to say
and implement it as instructed sincerely
Jason so thanks for that question Jason
a long email about how it was worth
reading because I think a lot of people
might have similar situations sorry to
hear about the job it could be a
blessing in disguise I think for you
it's great that you have a passion that
you're searching for you know what it is
you're looking at and it's also great
you have a supportive wife who wants you
to be all you can be as well you'll
notice at least that I found when
entrepreneurs really take off is when
they make that shift in their mindset to
feel like they deserve better and I've
always found that whatever holds people
back it's typically limiting personal
beliefs so you think you're only worth
so much and so that's how much you make
and when you finally feel like you
deserve more and that you're worth more
then you find change you start to happen
you make changes in your life to go for
what you think you're worth so it's
great that your hope
overcoming these personal limiting
beliefs and you're able to take that
next step with your with yourself as a
and and support your family as well to
that process and just of what you should
do next I don't think I'd recommend
going after the network marketing
opportunities not not to hate on network
marketing but I think what you want to
do is try to do something that's gonna
teach you about how to be successful
with your passion so unless you're you
said you're passionate about personal
development and being a coach unless
there's something and network marketing
that will teach you that I'll probably
stay away and I try to find something
that will teach me about how to be a
good coach in that field or speaker or
create products or whatever it is you
see is your kind of end goal if you're
gonna get a job or if you're going to
you know earn money that's not through
your business it's always better to do
it to learn something right so I
wouldn't try to jump on something that's
really far away from what you really
want to do just to try to make some
money because if you're not passionate
about it if you just jump on some kind
of network market opportunity or other
opportunities if you're not passionate
about it and you don't really see it
helping people you're not gonna make a
lot of money from it you're gonna spend
a lot of time trying to do it it's gonna
be frustrating because it's not what you
really want to do and you're not gonna
end up making some good money from it so
strikes on all you know all three cases
the better way to go in my opinion would
be to try to find something to where you
can learn about your field so if you
don't quite know how you're gonna make
money yet as this personal development
coach maybe it's one on one coaching
maybe it's online maybe it's creating
products if you're not quite sure what
you're gonna do and how you're gonna
make money from it
I would try to find an opportunity to
work with somebody who's already in your
space so find somebody who you look up
to your respect is doing what you want
to do and try to go learn from them and
that may be getting a job it could be
doing something part-time from home or
it could be something full-time even but
the idea here is you're learning the
skills about how to run the type of
business where you feel you need to be
and you're making money at the same time
so you're learning how to run the
business while still making money
getting paid from somebody else the next
thing I want you to try to think about
is what is your specific niche or
value-adds going to be so personal
development huge space relationships
huge space
what is it that you can specifically
bring to an audience that's different
than everybody else and you may know
that and that's great if you do then
whenever you're talking to somebody if
you're emailing me or whatever it is you
want to be really clear in that extra
guy that you add if you don't know it
yet that's cool too as you're starting
up you don't know a lot of the things
about how you're going to position
yourself so that's part of the
self-discovery and if you're working
with another company you'll learn about
what you're really good at and you'll
kind of explore it a little bit more the
end goal is to be able to have a highly
successful business to hopefully make a
lot of money and to add a lot of value
to people's lives and that's the key if
you're looking at how much money you're
gonna make it's gonna come from adding a
lot of value to people's lives so what
can you do as Jason the coach who can
add a lot of value to people's lives and
from there you're gonna be able to make
a lot of money so working for somebody
else teaches you the process of how to
go through that and you just got to make
sure that it's in that industry the next
thing I try to do so you've you know
gotten some employment or a job working
for somebody who's doing exactly what
you're doing you're starting to figure
out how they do things and also what
niche you could potentially do the next
thing is to start part-time so it's
great to quit your job or in this case
you got fired or laid off it's great to
kind of go cold turkey and jump into a
business the challenge is a lot of times
it doesn't work out because you run out
of money too fast or you run out of
money you you put three months into it
and then you're out of cash you got
mortgage to pay you got food to put on
the table and so you end up having to go
back and get another nine-to-five job
which you hate just as much so the key
here is if you're working at a in some
kind of job or opportunity where you're
learning then you can start the Opera or
new business opportunity your own
business part time and then you're still
making money from your current company
if you will to support your family in
your lifestyle so you start part-time
start going after client after client
ideally you start around some kind of
service because it's low cost and you
get close to your customer and you learn
more about how you want to work with
your potential clients and you build up
from there that's how I would probably
do it ideally then you're able to build
roster you'll look to get to the point
of survival where you're able to put
food on the table and support your
family and then from there you can quit
whatever job you're at go full-time and
explode your business and you know
what's gonna work because you already
have a little bit of a stable a roster
of clients who are supporting you so
that's how I would do it again I know it
can be hard when you've just been laid
off to think clearly and be calm and
collected and cool and do what's in your
best interest sometimes emotions kind of
run wild and it's gotta be a really
tough situation I'm sure that you're
facing right now but that's what I would
do if that's your long-term goal you
really want to be successful as a coach
or in that personal development
relationship expert kind of field the
next step is to learn from somebody
who's already doing it and this is your
your long-term goal right it's not gonna
be you know tomorrow you're gonna be the
expert you got to commit to doing this
for a year or two years or whatever it
is before you are able to really become
that successful entrepreneur go work for
somebody else is doing what you want to
do learn from them figure out how you're
gonna market yourself and a specific
value that you can add that's unique to
you versus everybody else start part
time build a small scale of clients
build an income base coming from your
part-time business builders at the point
we were able to get to that survival
line and support yourself and then from
there leave the job you learn what you
need to learn continue expanding your
business full-time exploded become
hugely successful be the expert that you
want to be and tell me about your
success or port back I want to hear it
so hopefully that helped for those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up if you have a
comment or something to say that Jason
or we have a question about your own
business please leave it in the comment
section below I always read those and I
try to respond to everybody who writes
in so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you